welcome to this video playing the
national master Popeye Popeye trying to
identify the flag could be Slovenia even
but it's a very little flag so sometimes
hard to identify yeah it is Slovenia ok
we get the Queens gambit I'm gonna
Slavitt take my with my standard line at
the mode which I'm trying out and I'm
always surprised that so many people
still play Bishop f5 which is just in
comparison a bit passive but we compared
to Bishop g4 I mean but of course it is
a is a solid and reliable continuation
just feels a bit a bit boring to me to
play like that Bishop g4 is a bit more
interesting ok early rookie and so he's
may be preparing e5 what am I is is
there some way to what should be a set
up against this I can play Knight c3 and
just take everything off if he plays e5
and then go a form maybe I come on let's
let's just play it 94 this may be a and
reply
No okay i'm going to take the center why
not
really you have some other move than 93
I know he doesn't um what are we going
to do here Bishop f4 it looks looks nice
in any case let's just push the the
bishop first okay it gives me the bishop
am Bishop e3 just simply Bishop e3 or
now my queen now my queen does not have
a great place where where I should my
queen go maybe still here at Bishop like
we need to Queen B 2 or something I want
the Queen on a decent square it term at
the moment some are obstructing White's
position of it so where where do I go
with the Queen Queenie too maybe Queenie
to be two or something like that p 3
would be a good spot for the Queen
yeah that cannot cannot be easily
attacked okay let's let's try to arrest
the night a bit if I a 5 a-5 would
weaken the B file to be seven porn and
this kind of structure really really a
lot so it's not doing that I can go 85
now night goes to d7 I think or here
okay he wants to go to d6 it seems so
that he takes the form what about f4 is
this is this too loose on it is a bit
loose with it but it looks like I'm
getting a very strong Center so it's
hard to not pull out how to avoid it or
will not be tempted let's say by the
move it should be good yeah that's that
looks nice taking this this big Center
yeah this F both moves look good now
Bishop takes is also not bad but ok this
is 32 attempting be five yes night f5
but I'm probably yeah I will play it
anyway it's just too big too big a
center
okay how are we going to proceed now c4d
five something like that trying to just
then just crash through in the center
maybe I was really thinking he she
should go be sure to h4 what about
Bishop efore now is this not should
reform ok and Queen g4 I was thinking
for our goods structure why does if I'm
able to take care okay this is just just
very one-sided now okay if I go see for
he might have f6 okay let's insert a
useful I also maybe Bishop h4 is also a
move or do I simply double
c4 f6p can play a six
this is a dual idea see 40 p 3 and rook
f3 in case of that so if he takes I'm
going to play a look at three may be
here six it's impossible my time
no no takes they can take twice on it
can take twice only five no this is not
really happening right time warning I
have rookie 3 now I can take with the
rook here how ridiculous is that he said
that come on it is really a joke right
night yeah come on he got he got light
the flag was totally busted him
ok
dad's always a bit frustrating they're
basically gives you the point on the
plate and you don't take it
still not not at all easy for my phone
black check
check
I don't know nine seconds great yeah
okay yeah this is slice it's just
designs just as just general do losing
this position is really really you're
not easy to do I just need to be
precisely and and and it's winning but
what exactly should I do I mean this is
probably not the best move but I mean
the most obvious thing is to just double
on the beat seven porn maybe this is
really what I should do yeah let's see
this this and here here or what this is
just winning so so easily and i'm
getting a seven and everything yeah i'm
just just playing like a [ __ ] you at
the moment sometimes i really don't know
what it is doopty doopty three is just
just yeah it keeps an edge of course but
it's not it's not decisive or anything
and i just blundered e5 he could have
taken it already here even now I can go
back to the one and everything but yeah
I'm just blundering if I've and that's
so I'd right after I made the move if I
just keep my stuff together and not
blunder anything black is just better
just just worse here I mean I have the
big center and he's got a bunch of
problems what is black smooth here in
this position what exactly is this move
yeah I can play whatever just do do do
any move whatever I go here and just
write strengthen the position further
it's really almost like help made
problem the way I play sometimes here
like find a way to do so totally totally
dominating position and I'm reliable to
find it yeah and what he basically was
doing is he was complete
the neglecting the center after this
black isn't in a terrible shape and
quite obviously so but okay I didn't
didn't didn't convert it yeah yeah this
is just one way to play I could also
just keep everything on the board but
the this end game is just so
overwhelmingly good for whites that I
then I went for it but okay I screwed up
really okay thanks for watching